Britten's summoned the Chinese
ambassador over allegations a consulate
employee in Hong Kong was tortured his
Simon Cheng
he says Chinese secret police beat him
deprived him of sleep and chained him up
whilst pressing him for information
about activists leading those protests
in Hong Kong mr. Chang was detained for
15 days during a trip to the mainland in
August live now to Beijing and that
correspondent Andrew Thomas and do we
know any more details about these claims
from mr. Cheng
well the claims were put to a
spokesperson for the foreign ministry
here in Beijing about two hours ago now
and the response from Beijing was
essentially doesn't deny them completely
and say that mr. Chen yes he was
detained but he was detained for
soliciting a prostitute nothing to do
with what happened in Hong Kong nothing
to do with the situation there and while
he was detained all his legal rights
were respected well that of course goes
against everything that mr. Chang has
said in his interviews with The Wall
Street Journal and others which
essentially say that he was tortured for
the two weeks or so that he was held in
detention on in mainland China so a real
difference there on in terms of story
and interestingly as well the foreign
ministry spokesperson said that the
Chinese ambassador in London will not be
going to see the foreign minister in
London he will turn down that invitation
so real rebuke there to the British
government
now Peter a little bit more on the
Chinese response as well to this passing
of the vote in the US Senate which
really has condemned what's going on in
Hong Kong China in turn has issued a
very long and detailed very strong
statement condemning that vote in the US
Senate I won't read much of it but
suffice to say that they say that this
act by the US Senate passing of the Act
neglects facts and truth applies double
standards and blatantly interferes in
Hong Kong affairs the issue Hong Kong
faces is not about human rights or
democracy but about stopping violence
and chaos they call the US Senate they
say the US Senate has got a hidden
agenda this act paid criminal moves in
Hong Kong as pursuit of human rights and
democracy that is wrong this statement
says and it will boomerang back against
the US and towards the end of this
statement there's a real well
very male threat at all a very explicit
threat that if this act goes further and
is made law if Donald Trump essentially
gives his consent assent to this law
then there will be serious repercussions
and they China will have to take strong
countermeasures to defend our national
sovereignty the essence of the statement
there and indeed with this Simon Chang
issue as well is that all of these
issues are internal issues within China
Hong Kong which of course is one country
and then nothing to do with the British
government or the US Senate or indeed
the American presidency either so really
strong condemnation by China of all this
what they see as interference in their
internal affairs Andrew thank you